[Music]
undoubtedly weakened by the failed
Mutiny Vladimir Putin tried to project
strength from the steps of the Kremlin
you saved our motherland from the
turmoil he told a crowd of his security
forces in fact you stopped a civil war
he said
the man who orchestrated the armed
Rebellion yevgeny progosian has been
banished to Belarus where he may well
avoid formal prosecution
his Wagner mercenary Fighters have been
given a choice join the Russian army or
join their leader in Exile they're
supposed to turn in their weapons along
the way
in men's Bella Russian leader Alexander
lukashenka claimed to have brokered the
deal in a nationally televised address
he offered rare criticism of Putin's
response to the Insurrection
if Russia Falls we will be buried under
the wreckage he warned that's really
telling that Vladimir Putin not only
seemed paralyzed for the first about 15
hours of this Mutiny or coup but that
also didn't play a critical role in
resolving it himself yet if pagosian's
goal was to shake up Russia's military
command over the faltering war in
Ukraine he seems to have failed
Russia's defense minister Sergey shoigu
was still apparently in his job Tuesday
despite calls for his ouster my strong
sense is that we're really only seeing
the First Act of this process whether
the stage is Moscow and New threats to
Putin's leadership
or Ukraine is as yet unknown Russian
turmoil could be the opening Kiev has
been looking for as it mounts its
counter-offensive the Kremlin insists it
will not be deterred from its goals even
as cracks appear in its armor
Jackson prosco Global News Washington